[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti mi chiamo ruggiero
naccari carlizzi e ho 29 anni
oggi voglio raccontarvi la mia storia
il mio percorso professionale che per
negli ultimi anni si è trasformato
nell'inizio di un percorso
imprenditoriale
ma io voglio partire da un po indietro
voglio partire dai miei tredici
quattordici anni quando quando vengo
identificato da parte insomma della
scuola come come studente dislessico e
dunque questo permesso
travolgente perché per me andare a
davanti a una qualunque interrogazione o
verifica o compito in classe significava
era come andare al patibolo tenera
e andare incontro a un fallimento certo
e questo mi ha portato un abbassamento
di autostima incredibile tanto che io ho
un certo punto
stavo cercando di negoziato che i miei
genitori affinché mi facessero
rinunciare agli studi e questo è stato
veramente un
suo dire un percorso che non mi ha
lasciato niente di positivo ma in
parallelo
grazie anche diciamo alla passione che
che mio padre ha per per la montagna per
gli sport invernali
ho avuto la possibilità di
avvicinarmi a allo sport e soprattutto
allo snowboard e dunque
a 14 anni o avevo trovato questo diciamo
questa sfera in cui mi trovavo
perfettamente a mio agio mi sentivo mi
sentivo me stesso e inoltre sentivo di
una differenza della scuola mi sentivo
di poter finalmente dare qualcosa di
riuscire ad esprimere del valore e
questo mi rende felicissimo io ho
iniziato con con gare a livello
regionale per poi insomma grazie ai
buoni risultati arrivare anche a fare
delle gare a livello
nazionale e vincerle poi riuscirà
diciamo a plasmarmi poi su un
palcoscenico
agonistico a livello internazionale e
qui arrivarono insomma una serie di una
serie di soddisfazioni e di
e diventi chiede che non fecero che
rialzare quella che era un po la mia
autostima rasa al suolo dallo studio del
percorso scolastico e dunque in questa
fase
io apro c'è per la prima volta diciamo
il mondo del lavoro perché all'epoca
facendo delle competizioni di di
snowboard e io comunque sia se parlando
dei miei 14 15 anni in parallelo avevo
iniziato a gestire delle relazioni
durature con quelle che poi sono state
delle imprese che mi hanno supportato
come sponsor per tutto il percorso
agonistico e queste erano aziende
insomma aziende multinazionali brand che
sicuramente vi conoscete e che mi
permettevano appunto di avere un budget
per poter andare in giro e io insomma
per loro dovevo fare una pianificazione
di quello che era diciamo il mio
calendario di gare quello che sarebbe
poi è stato tutto il diciamo l'aspetto
di fotoni sentivo legato a appunto a una
remunerazione di foto che mi venivano
pagate tramite ma l'uscita sulle riviste
e quindi io mi trovai ad avere una
gestione completa anche se in minore età
di quello che era diciamo una serie di
attività che in realtà non non mi sarei
mai aspettato invece di poter compiere
su quello che era diciamo invece la
serie di insoddisfazione che avevo
vissuto precedentemente con la scuola e
quindi io qua mi sento di dare una sorta
di messaggio un consiglio ed è là dove
insomma c'è la possibilità di
intravedere un qualcosa che
effettivamente
si realizza cc da soddisfazioni ci fa
sentire effettivamente di e di valere
qualcosa a questo punto conviene
effettivamente investirci un maggiore il
maggiore quantitativo di risorse di di
attenzione possibile perché questo tipo
di attività poi effettivamente ho questo
tipo di di consapevolezza di noi stessi
ci porterà poi effettivamente ad avere
un approccio migliore anche in tutte le
altre attività che facciamo io
mi sono reso conto comunque se attorno
ai vent'anni che
lanciamo all'attività professionale di
snowboarder avrebbe avuto comunque sia
una data di scadenza che non avrei
potuto farlo per tutta la vita
quindi
insomma dove dimettermi l'anima in pace
e
considerare come stavano facendo anche
di tutti quanti i miei coetanei iniziare
un percorso universitario
quindi io insomma mi iscrisse allo iulm
e inizia a fare il corso di
comunicazione marketing e il mio
principale obiettivo era quello di
emulare di riuscire a fare quello che
avevo visto fare da vicino perché
effettivamente mi sembrava possibile
e quello che ho visto fare da vicino era
effettivamente fare il lavoro che
facevano i meeting manager quindi le
persone responsabili dei brand che mi
rappresentavano o anziché io
rappresentavo e
man mano che però io insomma sono andato
avanti con il percorso scolastico
percorso universitario mi sono reso
conto che effettivamente quella non era
realmente non era realmente il ruolo che
io volevo ricoprire all'interno di
un'azienda volevo vedere un azienda che
tramite insomma una dimensione ridotta
potesse farmi capire come come questa si
muoveva come come riusciva a
implementare delle strategie come come
riusciva per la raggiunge degli
obiettivi e questo chiaramente non mi
sarebbe stato possibile se come come
azienda avresti scelto una realtà una
realtà insomma una multinazionale magari
con 10 15 20 mila dipendenti dove nella
migliore delle ipotesi sarei finito
all'interno di un dipartimento dove
magari mi sarei riuscito a specializzare
in maniera diciamo
altissima superò un determinato
verticale io quello non era la mia
ambizione io volevo vedere qualcosa
insomma vuole vedere un sistema che si
muoveva in maniera intera e questo era
possibile principalmente soltanto in in
un'azienda di dimensioni ridotte come
per esempio una start up
insomma erano erano gli anni in cui si
sentiva sempre più parlare di start up e
insomma la mia volontà era quella di
riuscire in qualche modo
a vederne una da vicino riuscire a
scoprire quello che stava succedendo in
questi in questi ecosistemi in europa
negli stessi anni c'era c'era un ottimo
ma c'era un fermento in germania
nell'ecosistema start up e c'erano un
sacco di realtà da un punto di vista
digitale e tecnologico che che stavano
nascendo non sto scherzando stampano
centinaia di mail che ho mandato scritto
su linkedin a qualunque persona ho
mandato ho cercato di anche di trovare
all'interno dei miei contatti qualche
persona che effettivamente mi riuscisse
a linkare a una di queste esperienze e
dunque dopo dopo un mese di ricerca
ricevetti diciamo una prima
manifestazione di interesse che poi
effettivamente si trasforma in una
proposta di lavoro in questa azienda che
si chiama stai light e che aveva
l'intenzione di aprire anche il segmento
diciamo italiano quindi voleva aprire il
mercato italiano e quindi ma ancor prima
di firmare alcun tipo di contratto mi
trasferì a monaco di baviera dove loro
avevano la led corte la loro sede
operativa dunque
questa azienda quara interessantissimo e
la vedevo come qualcosa di magnifico
perché si occupava nella stessa maniera
di skyscanner nel settore diciamo dei
dei voli aerei di identificare quello
che era il best deal da un punto di
vista diciamo ddd di
carattere che potevano essere appunto il
prezzo piuttosto che la taglia in tutti
quelli che erano diciamogli commerce sui
marketplace presenti online quindi
andando su questa piattaforma 1 riusciva
ad essere linkato una su quello che era
il migliore per quello che stava
cercando e dunque poco prima di
effettivamente mettere le mani in pasta
questa azienda qui decise di smettere o
comunque di mettere in stand by quello
che era il progetto
legato all'italia quindi allo sviluppo
del mercato italiano insomma a me
era caduto il mondo addosso in quel
momento perché mi ero trasferito
effettivamente non avevo un posto di
lavoro ancora nessun tipo di certezza in
mano ma
avevo un sacco di speranza è in realtà
ho deciso di rimanere lì qualche giorno
in parallelo alla ragazza la manager chi
avrei dovuto poi supportare in questa
azienda disse che aveva un fidanzato che
questo fidanzata si stava occupando di
sviluppare come stava facendo e
d'altronde lei il mercato italiano di
un'azienda di mobilità di trasporto
persone su autobus insomma io ero
rimasto un attimo
sconvolto perché io mi ero trasferito
una con una certa diario volevo andare a
lavorare nel fashion e nella tecnologia
del fashion
insomma mi viene fatta la proposta che
aveva niente a che fare con quello ma
insomma era una era una possibilità di
mettere finalmente le mani in pasta e
cosa successe
io mi andai ad analizzare effettivamente
cosa questa zona stesse facendo e rimane
rimasi folgorato perché questa azienda
stava facendo di qualcosa di ancora più
travolgente
destructive come si dice in gergo start
up e tramite diciamo una rete di aziende
tramite un azienda di trasporto che
lavoravano sotto una specie di gemo di b
gli accordi di partnership e sotto lo
stesso cappello era in grado di erogare
un servizio omogeneo in tutta la
germania e questo era un progetto che
loro volevano riuscire ad espandere
nella stessa maniera anche in italia
ma era qualcosa di sconvolgente perché
era il modo migliore per ottimizzare due
mondi che effettivamente erano erano non
interconnessi bene quindi il mondo della
tecnologia della del digitale della
della strategia aziendale è quello
invece della
dell'imprenditoria un po più come si può
dire vecchia scuola e quindi o dopo dopo
pochissimi giorni insomma che mi era
stata fatta questa questa proposta
iniziale mimì mi piomba a ad affiancare
andrea andrea con di che in realtà
l'attuale amministratore delegato di
questa azienda che si chiama flics bus e
quello che è successo e che io mi trovai
in un ecosistema dove
davanti a noi avevamo diciamo l'ufficio
dei fondatori a fianco a noi avevamo
l'ufficio delle risorse umane destra a
destra avevamo invece il reparto
marketing sotto di noi avevamo l'ufficio
delle operations è quello dello sviluppo
informatico insomma i 400 metri quadri
c'era c'era una zona che si stava
muovendo in maniera galattica e per me è
stato diciamo un qualcosa di magnifico
potermi immergere in un ecosistema del
genere dunque
il secondo messaggio che che mi sento di
condividere il fatto di sembra banale ma
di piombarsi fuori da quelle che sono le
comfort zone perché solamente in questo
modo poi effettivamente uno ha la
possibilità di intercettare le
opportunità anche se magari così stupidi
non non sembrano ancora dell'opportunità
o comunque non lo sono ancora ma in
questo modo uno effettivamente la
possibilità di mettersi in gioco
dunque
c'è voluto un anno prima che si
riuscisse a sbloccare tutto tutto il
lavoro burocratico e diciamo di
pianificazione per effettivamente poi
passare a da applicare quello che era un
modello già funzionante in germania in
quello che poi sarebbe stato insomma il
mercato italiano è stato complesso
ma ho imparato un sacco in questo
diciamo in questo lasso di tempo ha
avuto la possibilità di cosa che non
sarebbe successo appunto in una
grandissima corpo di mettere le mani in
pasta di avere dei ruoli attivi di di
creare
e io avevo 22 anni in senso non ci sono
tante realtà che soprattutto anche un
panorama classico di aziende che che ti
danno la possibilità di fare di
interagire con interlocutori esterni
dunque questo è stato un qualcosa di
fantastico nel 2015 finalmente riusciamo
ad aprire la prima linea che operava nel
settore nel segmento italiano
la prima linea che andava da una città
italiana un'altra città italiana e
insomma è ad oggi questa azienda qua di
mobilità è passata da non esistere nel
2015 inizio del 2015 ad avere diverse
centinaia di autobus che corrono per
strada e spostano milioni di
di passeggeri ogni mese dunque
questo è stato sicuramente una cosa
fantastica ma diciamo
l'aspetto che più sono felice è stato il
fatto di riuscire ad essere stato
immerso in un contesto dove c'erano
altri ragazzi altre
altri giovani che avevano
tanta passione quante ne avevo io
persone che però si muovevano in altri
campi persone che magari erano più
specializzati appunto nel marketing
persone che erano specializzati in
aspetti finance persone che erano
specializzati in
my name inning in aspetti più operativi
però c'erano tanti ragazzi che con cui
si passa tanto tempo e ci si è imparato
a conoscere abbiamo iniziato a fare un
sacco di di pensieri tanto che ad un
certo punto iniziamo
a vagliare l'idea di
poter applicare effettivamente lo stesso
modello che eravamo stati in grado di
sviluppare di applicare nel settore
dell'autotrasporto
anche in altri settori che avevano
determinate lacune da un punto di vista
tecnologico che meno comunque dei limiti
e che avevano comunque la possibilità
anche di essere ottimizzate
dunque
c'è un terzo messaggio che chi mi sento
di condividere ed è il fatto di
considerare le persone perché le persone
sono quelle che effettivamente per
costituiscono un azienda si sente a
volte parlare di idee sconvolgenti ma
un'idea senza un'esecuzione rimane
un'idea el esecuzione e viene svolto da
un gruppo di persone un team di persone
appassionate che rincorrono lo stesso
obiettivo in questo modo quasi può
creare effettivamente un'azienda
da qui è insomma
partirono una serie di brainstorming che
ci portarono a valutare in quale settore
effettivamente fosse possibile applicare
lo stesso modello che stavamo gestendo
nel settore della
della mobilità persone e ed
effettivamente c'erano resi conto che un
po perché siamo anche italiani e un po
perché avevamo visto da vicino che
c'erano determinate lacune in questo
settore
avevamo capito che nel settore food and
beverage c'era la possibilità di fare
qualcosa
e quindi ci siamo ci siamo messi a a
creare una prima versione di piattaforma
dell'azienda che che ho fondato insieme
a quali menti che si occupava di di
distribuire prodotti da parte di una
rete di nostri parà di partner che erano
aziende di distribuzione o a 0
produttori stessi e consegnarle
direttamente ai ai clienti e questo
successe poco prima del
dello scoppio di 19 comunque ci trovammo
poi con con marzo del 2020 ad essere
sommersi da ordini e io stesso mi trovai
a ad andare a mettere in certi casi
durante la notte quando non si poteva
uscire di casa
flier attaccati a
macchine citofoni e addirittura in certi
casi quando c'era un over the man da
parte dei dei nostri clienti a
supportare addirittura le nostre aziende
logistiche per andare in consiglio
quindi mi mettevo le cassettine di
prodotti alimentari in macchina andava
in consegna
dunque verso la fine di questa prima
ondata di co lead ci troviamo però
sommersi da un mare di competizione
c'era la qualunque c'era o qualunque
azienda che era andata online oppure il
negozietto sotto casa che si era creata
una piattaforma o comunque sia uno
spazio per vendere i loro prodotti e
quindi io mi resi conto che c'era da da
reinterpretare il modello è trovare
qualcos'altro in cui poter generare
valore ed era effettivamente
un settore che era ancora più profondo
di quello che avevamo inizialmente
considerato nel mercato retail ed è il
settore dell'oreca il settore della
ristorazione
teramo resi conto che era un modello che
era ancora bloccato gli anni 50 dove ci
sono agenti che vanno fisicamente a
prendere ordini che possa essere con un
tablet ma a volte può essere via mail o
via telefono non esiste alcun tipo di
trasparenza in meno di dieci mesi perché
alla fine questo è successo
all'incirca dieci mesi fa abbiamo già
servito un centinaio di partite iva un
centinaio di ristoranti o comunque sia
di botteghe e abbiamo circa una trentina
di realtà che si rivolgono a noi su base
settimanale o addirittura giornaliera e
quindi io vorrei concludere mio discorso
quindi vedendo un altro un altro
messaggio ed è
semmai vogliate intraprendere un
percorso un
[Musica]
volete potete mai lanciare un impresa
dovete mettere in conto che ci saranno
un sacco di alti e bassi e la garanzia
che saranno sicuramente più i bassi che
gli altri anche se poi quelli che
emergono e vengono raccontati sono
principalmente gli altri quindi bisogna
secondo me riuscirà aver ben chiaro il
perché
1 voglio fare una determinata cosa
perché quel perché sarà l'unica cosa che
effettivamente ci porterà avanti anche
nei momenti più bui
grazie
[Applauso]